madame la ministre samedi dernier dans
le calme la bonne humeur et une ambiance
festive près de quatre cent mille
français dans une univers une diversité
d'âge de conditions d'engagement
associatif ou politique ont manifesté
pour que soit revue à la hausse
l'ambition de la france en matière
d'écologie au lendemain de la grève de
la jeunesse pour le climat fustigeant
dans les deux cas l'inaction du
gouvernement
je note que cela vous a laissé sans voix
et sans réaction quand les airs nicolas
hulot claqué la porte en regrettant la
politique des petits pas autrement dit
l'immobilisme
madame la ministre les français vous
exhorte à agir aujourd'hui
pouvez vous donc nous dire quelle est
l'ambition du gouvernement sur votre
politique en faveur du climat et la
promotion d'une écologie positive plutôt
que punitive pour vous répondre la
parlait là madame la secrétaire d'état
auprès de lui de la transition
écologique et solidaire
la ministre monsieur le président du
sénat mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur russe on vous avait
cité la mobilisation des jeunes et la
mobilisation de nos concitoyens pour le
climat vous avez bien fait parce que ces
mobilisations sont salutaires et elles
sont importantes
nous avons besoin d'une prise de
conscience nous avons besoin d'une
volonté commune pour agir et pousser au
maximum la transformation écologique et
solidaire dont notre pays a besoin et
dont d'ailleurs le monde entier a besoin
ces marches sont importantes de même que
les débats qui ont eu lieu et je pense
au débat qui a eu lieu avec le président
de la république à gréoux les bains avec
de nombreux jeunes qui ont été également
interpellé le président en la matière et
demain nous rencontrerons avec jean
michel blanquer françois de rugy brune
poirson et gabriela talent des lycéens
qui ont participé aussi à des débats
dans leur établissement
il ne s'agit pas d'être interpellé les
uns contre les autres il ne s'agit pas
d'être opposés les uns aux autres il
s'agit ensemble d'agir pour cette
transformation écologique au ministère
de la transition écologique nous sommes
à la tâche tous les jours nous n'avons
pas attendu ces mobilisations pour agir
nous sommes déterminés nous avançons en
matière énergétique
la prèze la bonne programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie a été
présenté récemment en 2020 fermeront les
deux premières
thor nucléaire en france à fessenheim
nous avons signé le projet de territoire
d'ici 2022 fermeront les quatre
centrales à charbon qui reste en
métropole cette transition et est en
cours elle est faite avec les
territoires que nous accompagnons nous
créons l'office français de la
biodiversité en matière de biodiversité
nous mettons en place le onzième parc
naturel nous partageons mieux la
ressource en eau à travers les assises
de l'eau nous sommes à la tâche tous les
jours et sur l'économie circulaire nous
avons présenté une feuille de route de
l'économie circulaire qui va également
nous permettre d'être ambitieux en la
matière et cette feuille de route
arrivera prochainement devant
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat le
président de la république l'a dit à gré
où il faut aller plus vite plus loin
plus fort
ce sera aussi l'enjeu de la sortie du
grand débat que de proposer une feuille
de route complémentaire pour être au
rendez-vous de la transition écologique
et solidaire
merci la mission réponses convenues
madame la ministre je le dis très
simplement le gouvernement reste petit
bras un moment où en fait vous avez
affaire un dossier pour le moins
préoccupant et il ne faut surtout pas à
geler les ambitions en plein
réchauffement climatique je vais vous
donner quelques exemples la ppe
maintes fois repoussé dont on peine à
voir une ligne directrice la trajectoire
carbone pour le moins indécise le
développement des énergies alternatives
balbutiant la sortie du nucléaire aussi
peu sereine que le dossier de fermeture
des centrales à charbon et puis la
fiscalité verte mis sous le tapis depuis
la crise ils gilet jaune et qui risque
de demeurer longtemps un maquis où se
cachent mécontentement injustice et
colère madame la ministre
l'inaction écologique c'est aussi 100
milliards par an consacrés au traitement
de la pollution de l'air la facture
énergétique ces 40 milliards de déficit
c'est à dire deux tiers du déficit du
commerce extérieur
alors faites confiance à vos partenaires
les collectivités territoriales
auxquelles je vous offre une belle
occasion de proposer sans délai une
nouvelle grande oie pacte 2 un plan
d'action pour le climat est la
transition écologique
madame la ministre il est temps d'agir
ou jupiter rist de risque de devenir et
hall le dieu du vent merci